(calm music)
(upbeat music)
- Hey, come on in!
(80s-style rock)
Yeah, push and believe.
You got it!
Nikki.
- What?
Wow!
- I didn't mean to
catch you off guard.
- You kinda did.
What is this?
- This is actually prune juice.
- Okay.
- And we do have champagne.
We do have some bubbly
to celebrate the moment.
- Right.
- We do have food options.
I have flown into Boston
fresh lobster from Alaska.
- Why?
- The lobster, the water's
actually a cooler--
It's a Pacific lobster.
- Okay.
- So go ahead and
take a look at that.
- I am--
Oh, my God!
- [Brody] Yes!
- I'm really psyched about this!
- We have French fries.
We have cole slaw.
I will go ahead and pour
you some prune juice.
- I would love some.
I am just, I'm so thirsty.
- You got it.
(slow jazz music)
That's just prune juice for you.
- Thank you.
- [Brody] And then I
am going to celebrate.
- Do it.
- Here we go.
Whoo!
Enjoy!
- Go, go!
Oh, my God.
You okay?
- Mmhmm.
(sighs) Delicious.
All right.
- You want to get into this now?
Oh, God.
- Wow, you are an expert.
- I love seafood.
- What's the key
to opening this?
- You just take the fork,
and you take the first prong.
- Okay, I grabbed it.
- Oh, wow!
- I just grabbed it.
- Yeah, rip that
little part off.
- Not bad.
- Right?
- Delicious.
- Ew.
A lot of goop.
- Oh, you got a lot
of goop in that.
I'll tell you what.
If you're not happy with that--
- I'm happy!
I'm so happy.
- I'm just going to
give you another option.
- Okay.
- [Brody] Okay.
If you are into meat products--
- Oh my God.
The animals that
had to die for this.
- We do have some sausage.
- Mmhmm.
I'm totally good with lobster.
- Okay.
You sure?
- Yes, I'm sure.
- I also travel on the
road with my uncle's ashes.
Would this at all...
- Yeah, bring 'em into the mix.
What was his name?
- Uncle Eddie.
He travels with me, you know?
I take Southwest Airlines.
- [Both] Bags fly free.
- You are with me.
- Yeah.
- You travel a lot.
- [Nikki] A lot.
- What cities?
What are some of
your favorite cities?
- San Francisco.
- Been there.
Short drive, five
hours from L.A.
Where else?
- Not bad for you.
Oh, I like Kansas City.
- Fountain City, the most
fountains of any city
in the United States.
- Denver.
- Denver!
Mile-High.
Been there.
Tebow.
- Edmundton.
- Edmundton, the largest
mall in the world.
- Yes.
- One of 'em, they have a--
- Appleton.
Raleigh.
- Nik, is there anything
else I can get you?
- A glass of water.
- You got it.
Water!
Boom, yes!
- Wow.
Letting it breathe.
- Enjoy.
- Thank you, thank you.
- There you go.
There you go.
Well, Nikki, we
covered a lot of stuff.
- [Nikki] We did.
- Thank you for accepting
my offer to join me in my suite.
- Of course, of course.
- I wish you all the best.
And I'd just like to give you...
- Okay.
- A little hug.
- All right.
What...
Okay. (nervous laugh)
Okay.
Well, we can just...
There we go.
- That was a wonderful
moment, Nikki.
- Thanks.
- I'm the Lance Armstrong
of Comedy Central videos,
and I'm sitting on my
testicle right now.
Subscribe.
Comment.
Like me.
DM me.
Tweet me.
Send me an IM.
Follow me home one night.
Pedal with me to Twitter,
to Facebook.
Like the videos.
You wanna go bike
riding with me?
Do what it takes!
Go buy one!
(animal growling)